buenos días trotamundos bueno hoy vengo
a hablaros porque ayer me enteré por
instagram de belinda washington que
bueno de la historia esta de la chica
luna vale de la voluntaria de cruz roja
y desde el abrazo que le daba al chico
este
[Música]
el inmigrante que llegaba y estaba
sediento y le daba agua y todo bueno
tengo que deciros que visto bueno a raíz
de eso pues me invitaría un poco a ver a
ver qué era y bueno tengo que deciros
que hay gente muy despreciable o sea hay
gente impresionante
sabéis de todas las cosas que han dicho
de ella y de ese gesto que tendríamos
que hacerlo todo bueno
yo hace unos años estuve por áfrica
en general en gambia en guinea bissau y
teníais que ver como me han tratado fue
impresionante me trataron genial estuve
durmiendo en casa de gente los niños que
hay pidiendo por la calle en general
niños
de tres años que van con un bote de
tomate pidiendo
cuando me veían y les hacía hables
soledad los saludaba pues me
arremolinaban y me ofrecían lo que
llevaban de comer ya que no tenían nada
y me ofrecían
y
niños que la mayoría no tienen nombre ni
siquiera se es porque son abandonados
por los padres porque no pueden
mantenerlos entonces les dicen que vayan
a las ciudades para párate en que tengan
una vida mejor pues esos niños
son los que han crecido y son los que
quieren venirse para acá para nosotros
para con nosotros para
se supone que nuestra tierra esa que
defiende mucha gente tanto
y que luego son incapaces esta gente que
defiende en la tierra su tierra tanto
luego son incapaces de venir aquí a los
campos sabes bueno todos somos incapaces
de venir aquí a los campos a cultivar
los y sabéis quién trabajan que en los
campos pues toda esa gente inmigrantes
toda esa gente que llegó y aquí
afortunadamente pues están trabajando
los campos me encontré un montón de
gente de senegal trabajando los viñedos
y ayudando a echando una mano a toda
esta gente que nosotros no queremos
hacer sabes el trabajo que nosotros no
queremos hacer pero entonces a ver no os
deis golpes en el pecho de la tierra que
tierra está pasando ahora por provincias
y no hay ninguna cosa que diga a esta
tierra quiere decir que no hay ninguna
diferencia entre lo tengo en la tierra y
otra a nosotros simplemente aquí estamos
de paso y tenemos que vivir donde donde
podamos vale igual que nosotros nuestros
antepasados también vino aquí que a lo
mejor ni serían de aquí vete tú a saber
de dónde eran vale pues entonces pero
que no no la tierra no es de nadie la
tierra es de quien viva en el momento y
ya está de por favor
sabes vamos a hacer un poquito de
esfuerzo entre todos y ayudar a toda esa
gente que si vienen
unas por gusto es porque a mí me tienen
nada
yo
yo sería incapaz de hacer eso que hacen
ellos de pasar con unas barcas de madera
sabes y cuánta gente muere en el intento
yo también en en guinea me ofrecieron el
pueblo de pescadores donde estuve una
semana que me encantó que la gente va
impresionante
como me trataron
me ofrecieron ir a pescar con ellos
y me dio miedo
me dio miedo entonces imagínate voy a
pescar una noche y volver sabes esa no
era atravesar como atraviesan el mar
entero para llegar hasta nuestras playas
entonces cuántos de vosotros yo mismo me
incluyo cuántos haríamos el show por
tener una vida mejor no verdad nadie lo
único que hacemos es con el móvil
insultar a la gente que hacen buenas
obras
librada por luna y más lunas en este
mundo
bueno lo siento de verdad
es que ayer me indignó con mucha gente
buena
bueno quiere perdonar por esto de verdad
pero tenía que decirlo mira que nunca me
suelo meter en estas cosas pero lo
que hice esa chica con 20 años abrazar a
ese chico y darle de beber
guau
no sé cómo agradecérselo
ciao trotamundos
hasta luego